dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I hear some people
say that the most boring thing is
watching paint dry they have clearly not
seen this amazing research work that
makes it possible to simulate the entire
process of painting on a canvas we have
covered plenty of papers in fluid
simulations and this is no exception I
admit that I am completely addicted and
just can't help it
maybe I should seek professional
assistance so as there is a lot of
progress in simulating the motion of
fluids and paint is a fluid then why not
simulate the process of painting on a
canvas the simulations with this
technique are so detailed that even the
bristle interactions are taken into
consideration therefore one can capture
artistic brushstroke effects like
stabbing stabbing
despite the horrifying name basically
means shoving the brush into the canvas
and rotating it around to get a cool
effect the fluid simulation part
includes paint adhesion and is so
detailed that it can capture the
well-known impasto style where paint is
applied to the canvas in such large
chunks they are so thick that one can
see all the strokes that have been made
and all this is done in real time
amazing results traditional techniques
cannot even come close to simulating
such sophisticated effects and as it
happened many times before in computer
graphics just put a powerful algorithm
into the hands of great artists and
enjoy the majestic creations they give
birth to
you
Wow a two minute papers episode that's
actually on time great thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time